Well good morning church.
It's great to see you.
Uh, if you are new to our church, we're glad you'd be here.
We'd just ask one simple thing.
You'd introduce yourself to somebody.
There's a new here area out there just to help you connect.
We wanna help you find a place here.
Uh, but also if you've been here
for a long time, uh, we don't forget you.
We're glad you're here as well and we love you.
Uh, it's a joy to be together as we walk into
what we're gonna study today.
We're continuing our series through the book
of Second Samuel today.
We reach really the mountaintop of the book.
Many scholars believe this is kind of the pinnacle
of the entire Old Testament.
What we're gonna study today is God's covenant
with King David of Israel, how God made a promise to David
that was in part fulfilled in David's life,
but more so fulfilled through David's lineage,
through his genealogy, specifically
through the promise of a forever king
of an eternal son,
who we now know to be Jesus.
But two Samuel seven is the link
to all those promises made in the Old Testament
fulfilled in Jesus.
Now, why does this matter? Well, first of all, it matters
for our eternal salvation, right?
We don't have a savior, we don't have salvation.
Uh, and really we can argue that the entire Bible is one arc
of redemption as we would see it flow
through this covenant specifically.
But this also matters not just for that.
It matters for how we go about our daily lives.
See, if you and I believe that God keeps his promises
that he is faithful, that belief will affect
how we live our day-to-day lives, won't it?
Right? If you believe that,
that God keeps his promises he's faithful,
that means you're gonna be less worried When hard things
come your way every day you're gonna be less troubled
by the state of the world.
You're gonna be able to have joy in suffering.
You're gonna be able to have peace and chaos.
If you believe God is who he says he is
and he keeps his promises, that's
what you will be able to do.
That's why this is important today to remember
that we serve a promise keeping God who is good
to his people and faithful in all his ways.
If we walk away with nothing else, just remember
that and we'll be okay.
So God, we pray as that truth
would just settle into our hearts today, that you teach us
through your word as we've just been walking through it.
You show us today uniquely something you want us to see,
but not just to hear it.
God, as James says, that we would be doers of the word
as well and that you fill us so
with your spirit that we can't help
but speak of what we've seen and heard.
As Acts four says, thank you for being good.
Thank you for being faithful. Remind us of that truth.
Wash over us today as we need that in Jesus' name. Amen.
So look with me now at Second Samuel chapter seven.
We're gonna be just in the first three verses
to set the stage first.
Now, when the king, that's David,
when the king lived in his house
and the Lord had given him rest from all his surrounding
enemies, the king said to Nathan, the prophet,
see now I dwell in a house of cedar,
but the Ark of God dwells in a tent.
And Nathan said to the king, go do all that is in your heart
for the Lord is with you.
Now, as you'll see again in the chart we've been showing
most weeks, we're not completely sure
where this scene happened chronologically in the whole
narrative because in the next couple chapters,
we're actually gonna see more
battles that David has to fight.
So it seems like he's given rest here.
So we're not totally sure.
Regardless, we're now at the stage at least
where David's the king of all of Israel, not just Judah,
all 12 tribes.
He's the king. And
whenever this rest from the battle actually happened,
what it provided for David was an opportunity for him
to stop and reflect.
And you remember David's heart was oriented toward God.
He is a man after God's own heart.
And so his heart naturally gravitated toward worship
towards God.
And so as he did that, he sat back and he's looking around
and as he, he lifted his eyes to God,
he was convicted in his heart
that he lived in a really nice house paneled with cedar.
Probably was nicer than the old laminate wood paneling
that was in your room when you were growing up, right?
Like that's not what we're talking about.
These are like really nice cedar walls.
Okay, probably not look like that.
But the place where God's arc dwelled,
which was the symbol of God's presence with his people,
was some tent curtains around it.
Just a, a really comparatively low place
to where David was living.
So David was like, man, what's what's able, what?
What can we do to fix that?
Just as an interesting side note here, when
in this season of blessing it said David had rest.
He was living in a house, he, he was peaceful.
In that season of peace
and blessing, his heart was drawn toward
God, not away from God.
It's just an interesting check for us.
'cause often whenever we experience blessing,
when we experience rest, man, we drift from God.
Just be careful with that.
As you experience the the winds of God behind you
for a while, like don't run away,
press harder into the Lord.
But it seemed like for David, this was a logical move.
The ark is in a tent. I live in a nice house.
I wanna build God a house.
Even Nathan, the prophet introduced here for the first time,
he'll be pretty critical over the next few weeks.
He seemed to affirm this.
It seems like okay, seems like that's right.
Let's go for it. But watch what happens next.
Verses four through seven,
But that same night, the word of the Lord came to Nathan, go
and tell my servant David, thus says the Lord,
would you build me a house to dwell in?
I have not lived in a house since the day I brought up the
people of Israel from Egypt to this day,
but I've been moving about in a tent
for my dwelling in all the places where I've moved
with all the people of Israel.
Did I speak a word with any of the judges
of Israel whom I commanded to shepherd my people
of Israel saying,
why have you not built me a house of cedar?
Right? So God says to David, basically through Nathan, no,
David, do you wanna build me a house?
No, never asked anyone to build me a house.
In fact, I don't need one.
God says it's the same thing that the Apostle Paul said
to the Athenians in Acts 17, 24 and 25.
He says, the God who made the world
and everything in it being Lord of heaven
and earth does not live in temples made by man,
nor is he served by human hands as though he needed anything
since he himself gives to all mankind life
and breath and everything.
And so God's not worried about what people think about him.
Like, oh, he lives in a tent and this is a no.
It's not worried about that. He's also not in
that tent shivering because he's cold.
There's no walls. That's not at all the worry.
God doesn't need anything.
In fact, he'd been just as active
in Israel without a building to begin with.
And so what God did is he flipped the script on David.
It Wasn't what David could do for God.
It was what God had done for David.
Look at verses eight and nine
now, therefore, thus you, Nathan shall say to my servant,
David, thus says the Lord of hosts,
I took you from the pastor from following the sheep
that you should be prince or leader over my people Israel.
And I have been with you wherever you went,
and I have cut off all your enemies from
before you like.
So just in two sentences, what did he start with?
He says, okay, David, I don't need a house,
but here's what I wanna remind you of.
He started by declaring his faithfulness to David,
Hey David, listen, don't you remember?
And this is what God's saying.
Hey David, don't you remember?
Here's what I have done for you.
It took him two sentences, really simple but profound ways.
God reminded David of all his gracious blessings,
that he'd never left David alone.
He'd never left Israel, his people alone.
He'd never been anything other
than sufficient for them.
Just think about that for a second in your life.
Just a simple question. How has God been faithful to you?
When you think about and consider
reflecting on his blessings, on his goodness to you,
just a simple question.
How has God been faithful to you?
I'm not standing up here and denying that life can be hard.
I know some stories in this room right now.
Life is really hard
and even a lot of history can look like
anything other than faithfulness of God.
But, but I wanna just ask a question.
God has brought you
through every situation you've ever been in, right?
Just, just think about that. You're still here,
you're standing, you're pursuing the Lord, you're,
you might be crawling, but you're pursuing.
You want him. You're here for a reason.
You are still, God has brought you through every
situation you've ever been in.
You know why? Because he's always been faithful to you.
He's never left you. He's never abandoned you.
He's gonna bring you home someday,
and he's actually as hard as it can be
to see it in the moment He's actually working all
of those things for his glory and for your good.
He's always been faithful. He's always been good.
I know it doesn't always feel good,
and the enemy loves for you
to sit in those bottom line feelings that are real
that you feel,
but you have to go back to the top line truth
that God has always been faithful to you.
He's always brought me me
through everything I've ever faced.
He is faithful. He wants you down here.
The enemy wants you to stay here.
You have to keep coming back.
Often it takes us looking back at his faithfulness
to make sure we can better trust him in the moment today.
How's he been faithful to you? Don't forget that.
So God said no to David,
but watch this divine reversal
where God said he would instead build David A. House.
Now you hear that and you think, okay,
well God's gonna build a miss mansion.
Like that's what kings have, right?
It's actually very different.
Watch this verses nine through 17.
God says to David, I will make for you a great name
like the name of the great ones of the earth.
I will appoint a place for my people Israel
and will plant them so they may dwell in their own
place and be disturbed.
No more and violent men shall afflict them.
No more as formally from the time
that I appointed judges over my people Israel,
I will give you rest from all your enemies.
Moreover, the Lord declares to you,
the Lord will make you a house.
When your days are fulfilled, you lie down
with your fathers, meaning you die.
I will raise up your offspring
after you who shall come from your body,
and I will establish his kingdom.
He shall build a house for my name.
I will establish the throne of his kingdom forever.
I will be to him a father. He shall be to me a son.
When he commits iniquity, I'll discipline him with the rod
of men, with the stripes of the sons of men.
But my steadfast love will not depart from him
as I took it from Saul, whom I put away from
before you and your house.
And your kingdom shall be made sure forever before me.
Your throne shall be established forever in accordance
with all these words, in accordance with the vision.
Nathan spoke to David,
and so when I just read that church, those eight
or nine verses, whatever it was, This is the meat
of the covenant that God made with David.
Like this is the covenant.
This is the Davidic covenant God made with David.
This is what I was talking about when all of the Bible,
this is pointed to the pinnacle right here
of the entire Old Testament.
That's why you saw, right?
You saw what God was saying to David.
So much of the Old Testament points to this passage,
you go find the Psalms and prophets.
You see them coming back to this, pointing back
to this promise God made for David,
pointing back this promise God made to David.
This is the pinnacle of the Old Testament,
and this is the link with the New Testament.
So many of the New Testament passages quote this
far more than all the Old Testament, other passages we find.
We'll get to that in a second.
But again, let's just look at this covenant.
Look at what God said to David.
I'll make for you a great name.
I'll appoint a place for my people in peace.
I'll make you a house. I'll establish
your offsprings kingdom.
I'll establish the throne of his kingdom forever.
I'll beat him a father. He'll be to me, a son.
Your house, your kingdom shall be made sure
forever before me.
Just imagine David hearing this. Is that not stunning?
David wanted to build for God.
God said, Nope, I'm gonna build for you.
I'm gonna build for you and for my people.
He gave him this promise of a son, a promise of a house,
a promise of a throne that would last forever, a promise
of a dynasty, something that would last far beyond David.
He gave him that promise a prophecy.
Now, here's what's interesting about this.
This is a good example of what we call dual fulfillment
or partial fulfillment of prophecy.
Because what we'll find,
if you keep going past second Samuel, you'll find Solomon,
one of David's sons actually did end up by God's command
actually building what we call the temple a house
for God in a way.
And it was good. It was God's command.
It was, it was needed, it was fine.
It was nothing wrong with it.
It was part of the plan of God.
He did build a house in a sense.
But if you read carefully in verse 13
and verse 16, the word forever
was describing this son who would sit
and reign on the throne of his kingdom.
Well, David ended up eventually dying,
so he couldn't sit there.
His son Solomon ended up eventually dying.
So he couldn't sit there and Solomon's son and
and every other son who is the king of Israel from
that point on for the next hundreds
and hundreds of years, they all ended up dying too.
So This is pointing to something more.
This is why we believe that this is the covenant
that sets up the Messiah's reign
as the eternal king.
And spoiler alert, that's Jesus, right?
This promise God made to David was partially fulfilled,
but it was fully eternally fulfilled in Jesus.
That's one reason a year
and a half ago when we decided to
start going through one Samuel.
One reason was because we wanted to go in there and
and help us understand why the term used
of Jesus in the New Testament Son
of David, why does that even matter?
Why is that so important?
Because that is a messianic, a savior term
that goes all the way back
to the promises God made a thousand years
before Jesus showed up even a longer back
before that you tie the covenants together.
This chapter today is one reason the Son
of David term matters
because Israel was looking
for a savior king from this promise made to David.
They kept watching every king come
through like, well, that's not the one.
Maybe this is the one. Well, that's not the one.
Maybe this is the one. That's not the one they were looking
for a Messiah.
The problem is, again, every one
of 'em failed to fulfill it.
So they were looking for a messiah, an eternal
king that would come.
They were looking for it.
The prime time was when Jesus showed up,
and here's how the New Testament phrases it.
It says over and over, Jesus fulfilled this promise.
Gimme a couple, just a couple examples.
Two Corinthians six 18
and Hebrews one five, quote that son father language
directly and say, that's about Jesus.
It's explicit John two, Jesus said,
my body's the temple, not the building.
Hebrews one, eight, Jesus is the forever king
that fulfills the promise made to Judah.
Back in Genesis 49, 10, God said, Judah,
the scepter will not depart from you,
meaning you'll have one from the king line forever.
Jesus is the fulfillment of that.
Even the genealogy support this.
You know when you're reading through the Bible in a year
or two years or whatever it is, you get to the genealogy,
you wanna bail real fast.
Why does this even matter? Like we're just,
I can't say the names anyway, so why do I need to read it?
Right? Okay. This is why
you go read Matthew one, the genealogy there.
It points to Jesus being in the royal line
of David through his earthly father Joseph.
The legal fathership of Joseph goes back to David,
which then makes Jesus when you follow the trace
through the genealogy, Jesus is the rightful king of Israel.
That's what Matthew was saying.
He's like, guys, listen, this is not an accident.
He came through, David was promised this Jesus is the one
We could go keep going again and again over
and over in the New Testament, it all points to the fact
that Jesus was the fulfillment of the saving promise.
The eternal king. It was coming in the Messiah.
It's Jesus not fulfilled.
In hundreds of years of kings that failed,
that failed, that failed, that failed.
It finally came to pass.
The Son of David shows up, he's the Savior.
That leads me to the question next.
Have you trusted in this savior king,
have you placed your faith in
that savior king?
I mean, he set this up.
This is not just Jesus being some accident
or some kind of emotional pick me up that we need.
Jesus is the promised one to save his people.
All of the promises of God find their yes in Jesus.
He's the one who reigns forever on the throne.
He's where eternal rest and eternal blessing is found.
He's the only way out of your sins against the holy God.
He's the only way that can forgive your sins against him.
How He lived the perfect life. You and I couldn't live.
He died the death you and I deserve for our sin.
He defeated sin to death by coming outta the grave alive.
He ascended back to the throne of the kingdom
that he reigns now forever.
And all of that means you have to do something with him.
Again, Jesus is not just an optional add-on to your life.
He's not just a good teacher. He's not just a moral example.
He's not just someone you can go to when you're sad.
He's not a consultant to your life,
that you run it the way you want it to
and he just gives you some advice.
He is the revelation 1916 king of kings
and Lord of Lords, the alpha and the Omega, the beginning
and the end, and he's coming back
to judge the living and the dead.
And your only hope when he comes back to get outta
that is not just to agree
with everything I've said here today.
Your only hope is to say, Jesus, I place my trust,
my faith in you and what you have accomplished on my behalf.
You can't be good enough.
You cannot because you've already blown it.
And so stop trying. Stop striving.
Instead, just open your hands.
Open your heart to trust in Jesus, in your place
to count all else as loss for the sake of knowing him.
That's what saving faith is biblically.
So again, do you trust him?
Maybe You've grown up in church your whole life
and you've trusted in a whole lot of other things,
including yourself primarily.
Do you believe? Do you have faith in Jesus?
Because here's what ought to happen.
When I like, when I recognize my sinfulness
and I acknowledge God's grace
and his love for me, watch
what ought to happen.
David gives us a great
example starting in verse 18.
Watch this.
Then after he'd heard all of that from God through Nathan,
then King David went in and sat before the Lord
and said, who am I?
Oh Lord God. And what is my house
that you've brought me thus far?
And yet this was a small thing in your eyes.
Oh Lord God, you've spoken also of your servant's house
for a great while to come.
And this is instruction for mankind. Oh Lord God.
What more can David say to you for you know your servant,
oh Lord God, because of your promise
and according to your own heart,
you've brought about all this greatness
to make your servant know it.
Therefore, you are great, oh Lord God,
for there is none like you and there is no God
besides you according to all that we've heard with our ears.
And who is like your people, Israel,
the one nation on earth whom God went to redeem
to be his people, making himself a name, doing
for them great and awesome things by driving out
before your people whom you redeem for yourself from Egypt,
a nation and its Gods you established for yourself,
your people, Israel, to be your people forever.
And you, oh Lord, became their God.
And now, oh Lord God, confirm forever the word you've spoken
concerning your servant, concerning his house.
And do as you have spoken,
and your name will be magnified forever, saying, the Lord
of hosts is God over Israel.
The house of your servant David will be established
before you for you, oh Lord of hosts, the God of Israel,
have made this revelation to your servant saying,
I will build you a house.
Therefore, your servant has found courage
to pray this prayer to you.
And now, oh Lord God, you are God and your words are true.
And you've promised this good thing to your servant.
Now, therefore, may it please you to bless the house
of your servant so that it may continue forever
before you, for you, oh Lord God,
have spoken with your blessing.
Shall the house of your servant be blessed forever?
Is that not worship, just the whole time?
Worship. Worship.
It's a beautiful, powerful prayer of gratitude,
thanksgiving and praise.
Notice David moved from the throne room to the prayer room.
What he used to think, man, this isn't good enough
for the the ark, the tent.
I'm in the house of cedar.
He said, no, no, that's where I want to be.
I wanna be with God. I wanna go meet with God.
I don't care where it is. I'm gonna meet with him.
Israel's greatest king recognized his place
As he bowed before the true king.
And we see David's humility all over this, don't we?
He calls himself servant of God over and over again.
But look at verse 18. Who am I? Oh Lord God.
What is my house that you've brought me this far?
Like just blatant humility saying, God, who me? Really?
Verse 20, what more can David say to you?
You know you're serving, oh God, like God,
you know the deepest part of me,
and yet you still allow me to pray to you really?
And on and on. You did this God, you did this, you did that.
There's humility all over this as he worshiped in response.
And it was in response to what? To God's character.
Verse 22, you are great.
Oh Lord God, there is none like you.
There's no God besides you. That's nearly word for word.
If you remember months ago, one Samuel two, Hannah,
she prays this prayer so similarly,
there is none holy like the Lord.
There's none besides you. There's no rock like our God.
Like this is just character and character
and character who our God is.
That's why David praises his God.
Here's the point. Here's what he was doing.
He was declaring his faith in this.
David was declaring his faith.
He was responding to who God is responding to, all
that God had done, all that God had promised to do.
And David looks to God
and says, God, I believe you God,
I believe I I I have faith that you are who you say you are.
I have faith that you did what you did
and will do what you promised you will do.
God, I believe. Now you can also imagine
David saying, Hey God, I know I had to wait 20 years
for this moment, but I believe you because I can look back
and I can see how good you were
to me through the whole process.
I can see how you worked and brought me to this place.
And so I've placed my faith in you.
I placed my faith in your promises.
You See how this changed David?
See how he responded to God's blessing
of the covenant in his life?
I believe that God has worked similarly in those of us
who are believers even today.
And I think there's a response.
I think there's two responses that we should give
to God's faithful goodness in our lives as well.
Here's the first one, humbly rest in God's grace.
How do we respond to God's salvation, his covenant of
of eternal rest in him?
How do we respond? First, we humbly rest in God's grace.
What did God see? Or what did David see?
David saw God as good and faithful
and he rested in that we ought
to see God the same way.
I mean, just think about how he's
been faithful to you over the years.
Think of the specific ways he's been faithful.
Recount one by one, the blessings of God.
You know that word recount like we, we kind of use it,
recount what it means.
Recount. That means you go back and you number them 1, 2, 3,
and you go and recount 'em again and recount 'em again.
This is how God was faithful. This was how God was faithful.
You just keep going over and over and over
and over to remind yourself
of God's faithfulness.
And as you do that, you get assurance.
You take heart in how he's been a good promise,
keeping God over and over and over again.
So you think about his blessings, you think about
how he's been good to you, yes.
But then primarily
You Rest in God's grace for salvation.
You rest with assurance that the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus in your place, like Ephesians two
says so well, for by grace,
you have been saved through faith.
And it's not your own doing.
It is the gift of God, not a result of works
so that no one may boast.
I don't deserve it.
I could not earn it, which is what makes
by definition a gift.
Grace, you don't deserve a gift.
You're given a gift because you are loved.
That's the truth of this, that you can rest in the grace
of God for you.
You can be assured in the grace of God for you.
And that should make you and me
and us the most humble people on the face of the planet.
Remember what David started with? Verse 18, who am I?
Oh God, What?
What is my house that you would bring me this far?
That you would do this in my life?
Who am I God that you would do that?
Should that not be our response to God's amazing grace?
Should that not be the way we respond?
Like just stunned awe
that God would look at a sinner like you, a sinner like me,
and he would say, I want you to be a part of my family.
You're enemies right now,
but I'm gonna die for you so you can be with me forever.
Should that not be just like God? Who am I?
I don't deserve that. I deserve wrath
and you chose to love me instead.
So amazing His grace.
And the more we remember that the more we rest
in that grace, the more it should lead us
to respond like David did
and loudly rejoice in God's character.
We humbly rest in God's grace for us,
and we in return loudly,
rejoice in his character, right?
The bulk of his prayer was praise.
It was like, God, thank you for this. Thank you for that.
You did this. You did that. You did that.
Just praising God over and over and over.
That's what it was. I love this quote I found this week.
Grace should always leave us speechless,
Then make us speak.
Grace should always leave us speechless.
We're just stunned by the grace of God, who am I
that you would save me a sinner like that?
Who am I? Speechless, face first, humbled
before the Lord, which should lead us
to speak in response.
'cause think about it. How can we not
proclaim the grace and glory and goodness and mercy
and majesty and power of our great God
and Savior Jesus Christ like it should be on our
lips, in our homes, in our schools, in our workplaces,
in the public square, even amongst threats at our life.
It should be on our lips because he is worthy of it.
He's worthy of us declaring the glory
and the character of our God.
I'm so proud of our high school seniors this very week.
They've been planning this for a couple weeks
because our college students did it a few weeks ago.
So our high school students are like, let's do it too.
And so they got up every morning at 5:00 AM gathered back
there and said, we are going to pray
that God would give us boldness like
acts, we're gonna give, pray.
God give us boldness. We're gonna pray.
We're gonna worship together.
We're gonna ask God for specific things,
and we're gonna go out to our schools
and to our neighborhoods and we're gonna
declare the glory of God.
And you know what? They did it.
They were sharing their faith.
They were talking to friends in class.
They were inviting people to church left and right,
and they did it unashamedly.
Praise God.
And I got to pray with him a couple times.
And you know what? We clap for that.
But should that not challenge us
sitting there convicted by these 17, 18 year olds,
they're just like, boy, they're so far beyond me right now.
They were living out one Timothy four 12.
Let no one despise you for your youth,
but set the believers an example in speech, in conduct
and love and faith in purity.
College students, young adults did it a couple weeks ago,
did it again this week in some ways, and and they did it.
And the students did it this week. Why?
Because they are so grateful for who God is
and for what he has done that they can't help
but speak boldly and loudly
because they want everybody to know,
should we not be the same way?
Should we not rest in the grace of our savior
and rejoice in the character of our king,
like because he's been faithful to us,
because he has never left us.
He's kept his promises in every way he sent his son
to save us, and we're staking our lives on that truth
because of all of that.
Let's be bold for him.
Let's in here, of course, yes, let's sing loudly in here
because he's worthy of it.
But let's shout loudly out there
because people need to hear who our God is
not just here, but to the ends of the earth.
Like you heard earlier, he's worthy,
he's deserving of every tribe, tongue, nation, language,
people, group declaring that same glory of David's
prayer, our prayer, our songs,
our gospel message, that king is worthy of us taking that
to every person.
So I want us to just take some time to reflect
as the worship team comes back out.
A couple things to reflect on.
I asked the question earlier, do you believe,
have you placed your faith?
And I'm under, no,
I'm not ignorant of the fact that there's enough people
here, that there's at least a few
who, if you're honest with yourself
right now, would say, Nope.
Just kind of feeling this out. Not sure about it all.
It's okay. We're glad you're here,
but I'm good.
Again, gonna ask the question, do you believe,
have you placed your faith in Jesus?
And you could have been in church your whole life
and you've just played a game
religiously And you're exhausted?
Stop striving, trust Jesus.
And we'll have men and women along the sides in here as soon
as we start to sing and just slip outta your seat.
If you wanna talk to somebody about that, you got questions
about that, just go right over there, right over there,
and just go say, Hey, I, I don't know about this.
I'm not sure, or I just need some help
kinda processing through that.
You can do it right where you sit of course,
but just need some help with that.
We'd love to talk with you about those things.
But also just as we all kind of think like David,
David went from the throne room to the prayer room,
let's all just sort of go to that prayer room right now
and reflect on the goodness of God, the faithfulness of God,
how he's been faithful to you, how he has never left you,
never forsaken you.
How he has provided salvation through Jesus Christ for you.
And just let that stir an affection
for him in a new way today.
That we're grateful. God, we are grateful, Lord I,
I pray on behalf of all of us right now,
we don't even have the words to say
Enough to say thank you adequately.
So we just give you praise. We give you our lives.
Whatever you call us to, no matter the cost,
picking up our cross, following you
and saying, Jesus, you're worth it.
Help us. Take one baby, step that direction today.
In Jesus' name, amen.
If you're able, let's stand together
and let's sing in gratitude for who he is
and what he's done.